all right end of the year so that means
the traditional top ten movies of 2016
list of course I did not see everything
but I did see most of what I really
wanted to so I feel pretty secure in
this list as far as my tastes tend to go
now a lot of these I don't have
individual reviews for because I haven't
always had the time or the energy to do
them as I've seen these movies let's not
waste time to give right into it number
10 Deadpool this was just fun
I wanted fun I got fun and also funny
but it was more just sort of the general
vibe but I really wanted getting into it
light fun hey let's break this guy in
half cuz it'll be funny you know what it
is
good on you movie and surprisingly
potent of romantic relationship going on
in the middle of it too unexpected but
not unwelcome and Ryan Reynolds really
is a terrific pick to play Wade Wilson
he just plays Deadpool really well the
MVP though of the movie for me negasonic
teenage warhead all she's awesome and
there's been no particular mention
everyone's concerned or who's gonna play
cable or diamond on the in the next one
but she better be back
number nine 10 Cloverfield Lane this
movie kind of came out of nowhere we
didn't know it was a Cloverfield movie
the trailer came out I was like blah and
then we we saw it and it's just it's
good it's tight it's claustrophobic and
John Goodman oh man John Goodman we
needs to be in something that they will
give him an Oscar for cuz the man
deserves an Oscar I know he won't get a
nomination for this but he's so good
he's always good and he's so good in
this the movie is just tense and it's
perfectly paced and probably should have
ended about 10 minutes earlier I think
the ideal point to end would have been a
character I'm not gonna spoil it but a
character suddenly happens a character
has a line you've got to be kidding me
it should have smashed the black right
there would be perfect what happens
after
isn't horrible but it wasn't necessary
but everything up to that point was so
good that it didn't kill the movie
number eight Batman return of the Caped
Crusader's oh wait that was the right to
DVD it had a one-night special theater
engagement in select theaters I'm
counting it because I think it's awesome
this is just fun it is a perfect
recreation of that 60s TV show not just
in terms of bringing back the voices and
having people do impersonations up for
the actors who are no longer with us but
just the feel of it the vibe of it and
and taking that whole thing and being
true to it but take you to an extreme
that they could never do in the TV show
because the TV show didn't have a budget
to have all of these characters and it
wants and to do the kinds of stunts
these things do but it still stays
completely grand this feels like a story
that absolutely that show would have
done everything to have the budget to do
it it's wonderful it's hilarious it's
joyful it's great
number seven Doctor Strange I I was
expecting to like this movie I was not
expecting to like it as much as I did
especially knowing it was gonna be an
origin figuring it was gonna stick to
the Marvel movie origin template and it
does but I think it might actually be
the best movie that they've done that is
built into that template Benedict
Cumberbatch is terrific
the magic is really cool visualized and
there's just some really inventive ways
that it's used supporting cast is great
I love Tilda Swinton Chiwetel Ejiofor
I know people are saying that Mads
Mikkelsen was wasted I actually really
liked Ike Ilyas as a villain I mean it
could have been more to him I will grant
that but I still thought he worked
really well the resolution for the final
climb flicked at the end was fantastic
again it's fairly predictable in terms
of fitting that origin movies template
but it's so good they've really refined
that now I don't ever need another
origin movie for Marvel again I feel
like this is as good as it's ever gonna
get let's let's let's not do any more
like that number six
rogue one the most recent movie that
I've seen that is making this list and
this was exactly what I wanted out of it
because what I wanted was a movie that
was steeped in Star Wars in terms of the
tech and the world and the aliens and
was identifiable Star Wars through those
elements but was gonna have a completely
different feel and this has a completely
different field this is the Dirty Dozen
this is this is the people who fight in
a war who are not gonna get medals at
the end because nobody wants to ignore
the kind of stuff that they had to do I
love the all the Easter eggs I
personally thought that the CGI creation
of characters like Tarkin was fine
was it flawless no but I thought it
worked really well and some highlights
k2s Oh was wonderful and that all that
Vader at the end all ha ha ha ha yes
number 5
Moana now this one is kind of
interesting because in a lot of ways
this is Disney standard princess
template I mean really the only thing
missing from the standard princess
template is a romantic interest and
actually I'm really glad that got
chucked but even just going back to that
and just drenching it in this mythology
in this culture that honestly doesn't
really get a ton of recognition in terms
of mainstream films not with a lot of
respect at any rate and that is enough
to take those elements stick it on this
template that Disney know works its
stick in some great songs and it this
just clicks it just works
and particularly stuff that happens at
the end the way that the villain is
handled and the way that resolves is
really really good and really wonderful
and the voice work is great it's fun
it's energetic it's hilarious set points
man it really does nail that longing
that you want to get out of a good
princess character this is just it's
just good number 4 arrival this was one
it was not on my radar at all this was
so good now this is a movie you really
need to know what you're getting in for
I don't mean in terms of knowing the
plot but I mean knowing the pacing
because it's a very deliberately paced I
had
think to call it slow because slow
implies that not much happens there's
plenty of stuff going on but it's not
intensive stuff because this is a movie
about communication it's about us and
this alien race trying to learn how to
communicate with each other and that's a
process they meet it up they try and
communicate they get nowhere humans come
back they talk they try something else
they go in and they see what progress
gets made it keeps moving forward but
it's what it's depicting is not
whiz-bang action it's just not but it
never felt dull though this this is the
most momentous that a first contact
stories felt I think since Close
Encounters of the Third Kind now before
I get into my top three I want to do
some mentions couple of honorable
mentions and movies that didn't quite
crack the top ten but we're really good
and I want to acknowledge that they were
good and then I need to get to my
dishonorable mention so real quick
honorable mentions Star Trek beyond
which was very good and I did enjoy I
didn't follow up I know a lot of starts
with people that are really like on
board with this thing and praising the
heck out of it I liked it it was good it
just didn't crack top ten for me the
other one Kubo and the juice strings
again a very good movie not like his
best that's still ParaNorman and it
didn't quite connect with me the way a
lot of these other movies in
particularly with some of the animated
movies that I've talked about but still
really good and visually gorgeous as you
would expect now dishonorable mentions
let's start with my biggest
disappointment of the year and that one
has to go to x-men apocalypse which was
one of my most anticipated movies and
when the year started and then it was
just so it wasn't the worst movie of the
year
it wasn't even the worst comic book
movie of the year but it's so
aggressively mediocre even comic book
movies that I would say are on the whole
worse still had at least something that
I can go okay well there's that bit
there's that month this had nothing
there was nothing coming away from this
and the few things that
good we're complete retreads magneto and
his family they're just there just give
me there just remote evading magneto
with the same stuff over again the
Quicksilver scene we already saw it it
was good but we already saw it like it
just and everything else just it was a
white noise of a movie what a waste of
everybody's time
but the worst movie I saw this year and
I was so certain that I was gonna give
this to the little prince I was dead
certain but I'm giving my worst movie of
the year to the neon demon this is my
first encounter with Nicolas Winding
riffin as a director and I can't think
of any other filmmaker with their heads
so far up their own ass my god look the
things visually stunning I will give it
that but it's so empty there is nothing
going there's there's nothing there is
no substance under this very pretty
veneer everything is shallow and hollow
and it tries to go bonkers in the end
and that but that only works if I'm
invested I care and I don't was just so
full of it itself it's just so acting
like it was doing something profound and
just doing nothing
nein Yuri aided me worst movie I saw
this year but let's get back to the good
stuff let's get into the top three
number three Captain America Civil War I
mean what more is there to say about
this thing at this point I mean that
Airport fight Spider Man the emotional
impact of that final fight it's just how
carefully it's constructed how every
character gets their moment to shine
black panther just this was just a
fantastic just blow out I want to call
him finale but we've got more to come I
mean it but it's just it it feels like
such a terrific culmination and payoff
of the MCU up to this point and it did
this is something that you know they
root it in a real small more intimate
more personal story but at the same time
this could only exist in a world with
where all the other movies happen
first this builds of the existing
foundation so beautifully and I love it
number two the nice guys all this was so
much fun
now if you know Shane blacks work as a
writer director if you saw Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang the nice guys is to Kiss Kiss
Bang Bang as snatch was to Lock Stock
and Two Smoking Barrels it's basically
the same movie as something the director
did before but it's refined the rough
edges are taking on men it's just fires
on all cylinders Ryan Gosling is
hilarious in this thing I normally don't
care too much for him but he's so good
and so funny and Russell Crowe is great
and then it just keeps moving and I'm
like Kiss Kiss Bang Bang I actually
understood the plot but and but the
daughter character was great the world
was wonderfully sleazy and yet you still
kind of wanted to keep it and find out
more about what was going on in this
this was just terrific bonkers
fun it's so funny I laughed so hard in
this movie and I cannot recommend it
highly enough but I'm not gonna quite
give it the top spot the top spot was a
movie I knew it was gonna be on my top
10 after I first saw it and I will grant
part of this probably assume with how
many times I have seen it since but
every time I've seen it since I like it
a little bit more I find it a little bit
more clever I find another layer on
which it works I find something else to
like about it and that is Zootopia it's
just so well constructed in terms of
using the animals as a metaphor for
prejudice and to try and both make you
understand where that prejudice comes
from but also showing what you just have
to go to try and overcome it and it's
it's actually really really clever the
fact that the main hero is the character
with prejudice usually what a kids movie
tackles prejudice it's the villain with
this absurd prejudice that
has almost no basis in reality but this
is the hero the character we know we
love and we watched them come to
understand and we watched Judy realize
her own prejudice that she didn't even
know she had and to go back and watch it
again and I mean I have a kid who loves
the movie I've seen it more than most
people my age would have seen the movie
but just to see how carefully layered in
just her her not getting it for a while
and watching that all unfold and then on
top of that it's funny it's bouncy and
the characters that are to have terrific
chemistry it's wonderful voice acting
you know what I'll just come to it I
like the song I like the song by Shakira
it fits sue me
so there you go that is my list top ten
of 2016 can't imagine is the same as
anybody else's because how many other
people besides me around for Zootopia in
their number one but in any case what
were your thoughts on this year at the
movies there were a lot of things that
hit big there were a lot of things that
disappointed what is your top 10 or if
you just want to give a top three or a
top one or whatever you want to say drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast available on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned